joel is with us in seattle hi Joel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up yeah I've got a small business people
question for you
I own a very small business there's just
five of us and includes my wife and I
imagine just a few other team members
and I'm familiar with your no gossip
policies volunteer leadership material
as I really appreciate one question is
an employee this morning's been with us
for a few years approached me and was
sort of frustrated that one of our newer
co-workers let me see a friend of hers
was venting to her and basically
gossiping a lot of negative stuff that I
sensed might have been going on but
wasn't sure and so I appreciate that
she's approached me she did it
sensitively and they felt that doing so
but now I'm wondering how do I approach
or do I approach this other employee
without sort of calling out her friends
last co-worker for bringing it forward
how do I handle this in a way that's
tactful but it Jeeves the result we
hopefully want you know does the new
person know that you all don't are not
okay with this idea I have not been
clear enough I haven't articulated that
no gossip policies that look like what
clarity that I should okay all right you
know I might just pull pull her in and
say listen I'm reading some stuff and I
got to tell you I'm not okay with the
concept of this and and I kind of think
you're doing that right now and I'm
gonna go ahead and kind of warn you
right now that I'm not gonna be okay
with that in the future and she's what
me yeah you you know and you know you
know what's interesting is if you're if
you use a low tone and you're not
caustic in your sentence structure you
can say almost anything to people but
what happens is we get frustrated angry
and we change our tone or we change our
sentence structure to where it's toxic
but if it's just like look I kind of
goofed up I had this whole idea and I
thought I had told people better
I hadn't really told people as well as I
should so probably you didn't completely
understand
that we basically here have a no gossip
policy I will pledge to you that I'm
gonna tell people going forward that if
you have a negative you have to bring it
in here if you could bring it to a
co-worker ever again you and I are not
going to be okay and what you've been
doing taking it to other co-workers is
just not okay it's on me because I
didn't tell you ahead of time that
wasn't okay but you also knew it was
slimy to do that so you shouldn't be
slimy stop it yeah that conversation
could last that long they can last that
long it doesn't have to be a long
conversation and it's over and we're not
you know I'm not gonna beat you up I'm
not you know we're not you know we're
not putting you in timeout I'm telling
you it's my fault because I wasn't clear
but after today it's your fault and
really it was kind of your fault anyway
because it's just allowing me to do that
and you don't need to do anymore just as
a human being you know running down with
people who pay you is stupid and
disloyal you want to say that but it is
should I be worried if basically if you
you know you know that someone's gonna
tell you this or how do you know if they
bring it up and say you know what that's
not relevant what's relevant is I wasn't
clear and you were slimy so we both have
made a mistake and you're not gonna do
that mistake anymore and I'm not gonna
do my mistake anymore I'm gonna be clear
from now on
unbelievably clear and you're gonna stop
doing that
that's all that's relevant and if you do
not want to work in a place like that
then you should probably pack your stuff
because you've now work in a place
that's like that at our place the people
that work here don't do this and if you
do this whatever this is then you're not
gonna get to be one of the people that
work here and that's something we talk
about around here all the time
I mean odd infinitum every stinking
staff meeting I'm covering some kind of
a core value and I go this is how we
treat the customer this is how we serve
with excellence we bring it we're
playing for the Super Bowl every day and
we're not gossiping and we're not
running down anybody we're not running
down each other if you have a problem
not
if when you have a problem you hand your
negatives up and your positives
laterally and down you don't discuss
negative things frustrations with people
who can't do anything about them
that is a toxicity in an organization
and it destroys an organization and I
will fire your butt and I tell people
that about once a month from the stage
with 800 people in the staff meeting and
you know what we just we win the best
place to work every stinking year and
one of the things when they survey and
say why is it the best place to work
we love the no gossip policy the other
people love it and so if slimy girl
can't clean up her act and she's just
gonna continue be slimy girl then she
does need to leave you can get another
one that's better than her and that's
part of the that's part of the fear too
and so appreciate the clarity and pray
for the courage now yeah yeah and it's
just it's just listen its courage but it
gives you the ability to be kind
meekness is not weakness it's power
under control you're in the driver's
seat you own the place you control her
job at the stroke of a pen so you're in
a position to be kind to her but clear
be very clear and you've not been
cleared you admitted that so you owe her
an apology for that part but and don't
make that mistake again be clear from
this point forward and that's really
what is you got to get it out of there
you can't can't ignore it
in the name of protecting the informant